this morning's testimony by fired FBI
director James Comey is dominating front
pages across the country his opening
remarks were released yesterday and they
described nine private conversations
with President Trump most headlines
focus on how Comey says the president
asked him for his loyalties Comey also
says the president called him called on
him to let go the investigation into his
former national security adviser Michael
Flynn chip Reid is outside the Capitol
Hill hearing room where the testimony
will take place chip good morning what a
historic morning it is well it is and
I'll tell you a lot of people are taking
in this history you can see this line
back here the people at the front of the
line have been here since five o'clock
this morning and the line goes around
this corner all the way down the hall
around the next corner really literally
hundreds of people and a lot of the
people in line are Senate interns
they're here to see history being made
and their senate ids got them in early
so they're kind of hogging the seats up
there now we do know part of what mr.
Comey will say this morning when the
hearing begins he will say that mr.
Trump asked him quote what we could do
to lift the cloud over his presidency
Comey says the president also said quote
I hope you can let this go referring to
the Michael Flynn investigation several
times mr. Trump pressed an FBI director
Comey to pledge his loyalty the big
question though is what Comey will say
beyond his already released opening
statement we know he will not make a
legal argument but he will tell his side
of the story
senators on both sides of the aisle are
expected to push him to reveal more one
thing that's really important to note
here is that the investigation into
Russian meddling the congressional
investigation has been going on for
months and there is still no solid
evidence of wrongdoing by the Trump
campaign one reason this hearing is as
you can see so heavily anticipated is
because Comey is the first major witness
to testify publicly about what happened
Charlie thanks chip